catherine pégard bonjour le château et
le domaine ont pu accueillir leurs
premiers visiteurs ce samedi 6 juin
j'imagine que pour toutes les équipes
s'étaient déjà un grand soulagement
ouais c'était un soulagement c'est aussi
une grande joie de pouvoir rouvrir ce
château après je crois 82 jours de
fermeture et ici je crois qu'on aime
partager tous ce même sentiment de voir
satisfaites une attente qui avait
commencé le jour même de la fermeture
c'est à dire le jour où on a fermé les
grilles du château on a pensé au jour où
on allait les rouvrir et donc c'était
effectivement une joie mais c'était
aussi assez émouvant de penser à tout ce
que nous avions partagé et vécu ensemble
pour recommencer à j'allais dire à vivre
parce que c'est aussi un symbole la
réouverture du château de versailles
c'est le symbole que la vie reprend que
l'activité reprend bien sûr à versailles
mais bien au delà de versailles du point
de vue des visiteurs pour le moment vous
devez vous passez des étrangers qui
représentent pourtant 80 % des visiteurs
et oui absolument mais de toute façon je
crois qu'on est tous évidemment dans
cette situation est d'ailleurs dans tous
les pays c'est à dire que tout d'un coup
les échanges entre nos pays se sont
arrêtés et ce qui est tout à fait
nouveau c'est que habituellement si
j'ose dire quand un pays vivait une
crise est bien tous les autres pouvaient
compenser et venir à leur place est
aujourd'hui bien nous n'avons plus de
chinois plus de d'américains est pour
l'instant plus d'européens n'ont plus
j'espère qu'ils vont pouvoir bientôt
revenir en france pour partager l'été
avec nous au mois mais effectivement
c'est une nouvelle manière d'ouvrir le
château de versailles et c'est une
manière de dire aux français d'écouté
venet à versailles parce que vous allez
retrouver sûrement un château que vous
aviez peut-être oublié parce que souvent
on vient aversa quand on est enfant et
puis on y revient avec ses propres
enfants et parfois entre deux on va
ailleurs on va à l'étranger
et bien cette année puisque nous ne
pourrons pas voyager n'est les animaux
je pense que nous pourrons revenir ici
et découvrir tout ce qui a été fait
pendant toutes les années passées à
versailles
tout ce que nous
on a ouvert une soixantaine de pièces
depuis 8 ans ont créé des parcours dans
les jardins cette année vous pourrez
découvrir le parcours des arbres
admirable dans les jardins mais aussi le
parcours des statuts remarquable puisque
on ne sait pas toujours que le château
de versailles c'est aussi un musée de
plein air avec quelques 400 statues et
donc nos conservateurs ont mis à profit
ce temps du confinement pour faire un
parcours magnifique et qui permettra de
découvrir les jardins à travers et au
rythme des statuts 12 et un appel aux
français mais le public était présent
dès ce week-end tous les créneaux
réservés
oui je crois que les français étaient
ravis d'être ici mais parce que
versailles fait partie intégrante de
leur histoire est que justement venir à
versailles s'est montré que comme je
vous l'aï dit tout à l'heure non
seulement que la vie reprend mais qu' on
partage aussi cette histoire ensemble
le château de versailles accompagné
l'histoire de la france quand il ne l'a
pas fait et on constate qu'à chaque
événement heureux ou malheureux on parle
de versailles et pour les événements les
plus tragiques d'entre eux je pense par
exemple à la première guerre mondiale
la première chose qu'ils recommencent ce
sont les fontaines pour les grandes eaux
dans les jardins de versailles
et bien sûr il ya aucune comparaison à
faire mais c'est un petit peu ce que
nous avons vécu le week end dernier avec
des visiteurs qui étaient très heureux
de revenir versailles et qui nous le
disait et qui remerciait aussi les
agents pour le travail qu'il faisait et
ça c'est une grande satisfaction pour
nous tous mais vous avez dû revoir un
petit peu toute l'organisation il faut
notamment réservés quatre mille cinq
cents par jour on est quand même très
loin des plus de 25000 que vous
accueillez oui bien sûr mais je pense
qu'il faut il faut changer de regard a
changé de point de vue
en tous les cas pour quelques mois
j'espère pas trop longtemps
mais pendant quelques mois il faut
s'habituer à vivre avec des formats de
visites plus petits mais aussi peut-être
plus d'une certaine manière plus
agréable pour ceux qui vont faire les
visites
je pense que cette jauge nous n'allons
pas la garder éternellement mais pour
l'instant effectivement on ouvre les
portes de versailles d'une autre façon
puisque on emprunte un vaste couloir qui
permet de de se promener à travers les
appartements royaux mais en même temps
en étant assez concentré sur ce qu'on
fait et donc cette visite à mon avis
reprend des couleurs différentes pour
ceux qui connaissent bien versailles
dans les visiteurs qui viennent ces
jours ci il y a évidemment les les
abonnés les habitués ceux qui habite non
loin d'ici et qui retrouve versailles et
qu'ils disent mais j'avais pas remarqué
tel tableau parce que peut-être que
j'étais un petit peu trop pressés que
j'allais trop vite et est finalement là
dans cette nouvelle configuration
et bien ils font de nouvelles
découvertes et c'est très bien vous
allez avoir des visites guidées qu'on
pourrait presque qualifier de priver
absolument puisque lé nombre des visites
affalé nombre de participants à une
visite privée ont dû être diminuée et
donc ses visites privées qui permettent
de voir des appartements qu'on ne
verrait pas autrement parce qu'ils sont
trop exigus et bien vont effectivement
fournir là aussi à nos visiteurs
l'occasion de faire des découvertes qui
pour eux seront sans doute très
extraordinaire parce que ici à chaque
fois que vous pouvez c'est une porte
c'est une histoire qui se raconte
vous regardez à tableau est bien
derrière lui a aussi le travail d'un
artiste un meuble c'est le travail d'un
ébéniste les tissus qui sont souvent
évidemment magnifique et bien évoque des
métiers qui quelquefois disparaîtrait si
versailles n'existait plus donc c'est
simplement je crois qu'il faut toujours
dire que versailles c'est le passé et le
présent et c'est ce grand patrimoine qui
nourrit la création qui nourri notre
imaginaire et qui fait que nous avons
envie de le retrouver et on verra aussi
que les équipes n'ont pas chômé pendant
ces jours de confinement
oui c'était d'abord parce que nous
étions peu nombreux à être sur le site
puisque beaucoup malheureusement devait
être confiné ont dû faire du travail à
distance et beaucoup de travail à
distance et puis on a essayé de
maintenir la vie au ralenti peut-être
mais de maintenir la vie au château de
la saq pour que ce château de versailles
pour puisse ouvrir ses portes et revivre
sans qu' il y est tout à refaire par
exemple c'est extrêmement banal mais il
fallait faire le ménage donc l'entretien
a été fait de façon à ce que lorsque le
château de versailles allait ouvrir ses
portes et bats la galerie des glaces à
paraître
est insolente peut-être encore plus que
les années passées puisque ce grand
ménage n'avait pas été fait dans la
galerie des glaces depuis 2007
merci à catherine pégard êtes la
présidente de l'établissement public de
versailles et donc le château est ouvert
la réservation est conseillée surtout
n'oubliez pas vos masques